the one thing that limits every business
is the entrepreneur not the opportunity
not the business vehicle not anything
else it's the entrepreneur everything
stems from them there's three things
you've got the skills of the
entrepreneur the character traits of the
entrepreneur and then you have what i
would call the beliefs of the
entrepreneurs what do they believe about
the world to be true and what do they
believe about the world to be true that
isn't we have so many of these belief
statements that like quote society are
things that we inherit but we just
choose to say that this is how life is
the easiest way to think about this is
an analogy which is if you imagine a
ladder right which you've got the ladder
of success skills on one side beliefs on
the other side and then you've got
character traits in the middle as the
rungs you might have a tremendous amount
of skills and great character but your
beliefs are limited if all of a sudden
you see somebody have an overnight
success it's usually because they had
two of the three already very very high
level but they were missing some huge
parts some belief was wrong so for
example for me when i went from two
million to seven to just under 30 in a
matter of like three years i believed
things that were true about the world
that weren't i didn't know that
licensing was a model i didn't know i
could expand in that way and in so doing
i was able to explode because i got into
the right vehicle the vehicle wasn't
limiter it was me and my beliefs about
it and then as soon as i changed the way
i saw the world i was able to get into a
much better vehicle and explode from
there the skills we learn through
education education comes from
repeatedly doing things and learning
from that experience the information
that we acquire to learn things comes in
a lot of different forms now the things
that i actually invested in workshops
books seminars coaching programs
one-on-one tutors one-on-one mentorships
and google
and i would say if i had to allocate uh
amount of time spent learning things
google was still by far the biggest one
it's funny the other day i just set up
this new widget for our site i googled
it and i did it in two hours and so i
think that the amount of time that
elapses between wanting to figure
something out and doing something the
more advanced you get shortens i
remember it took me three years to
figure out how to build a landing page
and the day i decided to do it it took
me four hours so it took me three years
and then four hours to actually figure
it out because i was avoiding the
feeling of sucking and so if you can
confront sucking faster and just get
over that idea that sucking is a bad
thing then i think you compress the time
between you and the skills you want the
highest value i've gotten from is from
one-on-one mentorship is from people who
are far ahead of me that were willing to
speak strategically into my life and
that's usually because those people can
identify all three of those things they
can identify skill deficiencies they get
to identify character trait deficiencies
and they can identify things that you
believe that are true that aren't so
that is where i've gotten the most
leverage in my life is on and i've paid
20 30 000 an hour to many many different
people just to have them speaking of my
life right underneath of that as i was
coming up was joining masterminds it was
the getting around other people because
for me was very lonely and so just being
around other people doing things a got
my competitive drive up because i always
wanted to be the best and seeing people
that i didn't think were like better
than me
do something better than me
gave me hope that i too could do it i'd
see somebody be like i don't think they
were harder than me i don't think
they've got like some genius brain if
they can do it i can do it too also when
i was in those communities they would
also already have sifted through
information for me because there's lots
of information out there the problem is
that we have limited time so it's no
longer about oh information's free you
can find anywhere it's not free it costs
time to go find where it is and so the
idea is when you pay someone for
information it's not you're paying for
the info you're paying for the time it
took them to sort through it to hand it
for you so you're cutting time that's
what you're saving when you exchange the
money that's the idea i think a lot of
people don't get that this is the actual
order that i bought things so the first
thing that i did i did free interviews
so i tried to reach out to people so i
just said hey i'll show you the stuff
that i've got you want to share notes
with me i can drive out there we can
meet up and that's how i learned a lot
of my initial stuff usually it was older
guys who were willing to like you know
take a young young buck under their
under their wing if you're young the
advantage you have is that you're young
you can get a little bit of that
goodwill from older guys that you might
not normally get if they're the same age
if you were like well the millionaire
won't let me pick his brain it's like
well no [ __ ] his time's more valuable
than yours either pay them or you have
to go down a run you have to keep going
down until there's somebody that's
either a peer or just slightly ahead of
you who you can provide value to in a
very narrow way the next one i did is i
i joined a mastermind that was ten
thousand dollars and i was saying
backyard's mastermind recipes and he
actually took enough of a liking to me
that he said why don't you just become
my apprentice and then he started paying
me so it's kind of weird so i paid him
and they paid me back so i work from 4
a.m to 4 p.m every day with him
basically as his secretary and i learned
a ton three months just like learning
all these new terms sales copywriting
affiliate marketing i learned all this
stuff just from him because he was in
that world from there i started my first
gym and i stayed in that gym mastermind
during the time i also bought a weekend
workshop for
facebook ads i learned facebook ads in a
small group of 10 people in two days it
was really valuable for me then i didn't
really do anything for a couple years
and then i went to traffic and
conversion summit so that was an event
and i just learned more about marketing
in general i got introduced to different
softwares that i then started using and
then from there i kind of got more into
the digital marketing world so i joined
some masterminds in that world i didn't
do coaching programs myself i actually
ended up buying them for teammates i
think the coaching programs are really
effective to teach methods so if there's
a method of acquisition you want to
learn whether it's like youtube ads or
twitter ads or cold calling whatever it
is joining a coaching program but other
people trying to learn the same thing
from study who's good is a great way to
fast track your success it just gives
you the accountability it helps you
resolve problems faster what you're
buying is speed it's not that you can't
do it on your own it's that you can do
it faster with help if you're trying to
solve a specific problem finding
specific coaching programs is really
good if you've been stuck for a long
time i think that's where like
masterminds and 101 mentorship is more
valuable because you probably have a
strategic issue more than a tactical
problem now the beliefs kind of get
solved concurrently when you're in
communities because the best way to
break a belief is to see someone doing
what you thought was not real and then
have it happen a lot of people have
heard of the roger bannister story first
man to break a four minute mile and then
the next year 28 people or whatever it
was broke the four minute mile and so
the nice thing is that when you join
these communities the biggest benefit is
not even the coaching it's the beliefs
that are broken and the things that you
thought were false about the world that
aren't and i remember there was a moment
where i was in a mastermind and there
was a guy making i think 350 000 a month
and he got up there and he sounded like
an idiot and layla and i looked at each
other afterwards we're like if he can do
it we can do it that was when we weren't
even doing that much money we were
probably doing i don't know 20 30 000
like it was not a lot of money so when i
joined one of the first masterminds i
wanted to get my money's worth i want to
get as much out of this as i possibly
could remember be everyone's number one
student i talk to every single person in
the master i set up a call with
everybody and i was like hey i'm new i'm
good at sales that was my first skill
that i had i didn't have any i didn't
know what market i didn't know ads i
didn't know webinars i didn't know i
didn't know any of that stuff but i was
like i know how to sell what i did was i
just offered every single person to go
over their sales script edit it the way
that i would structure and then rewrite
them as sales script my way for free and
i did that with everyone and then what
happened is i had all these big stack of
ious and then i was like i want to get
into internet marketing and i was like
johnny was good at landing pages
hey johnny remember i have to do that
sales thing do you think you could help
me with landing pages sure man of course
okay what else do i need i don't know
how to run ads
hey sarah you were really good at
running ads remember that sales thing i
helped you sure of course and i get
one-on-one tutoring from everybody on
the things that they're best at because
i just gave everyone what i was best at
that's how i did it you want to become
the most valuable person in your network
and then in so doing you gain access to
everyone's network like joe rogan
doesn't need to network he just is joe
rogan and so if he wants access to
somebody he gets access then because he
is valuable i've never been a fan of
like the networking hacks it's just
provide value to people for nothing and
then you will have people who owe you
stuff you've got your skills you've got
your beliefs and then you've got your
character traits if there's one that is
the most important i do think it's
character traits because the character
traits are the wellspring that the other
things are are founded upon if you don't
have discipline you'll never be able to
actually study anything consistently to
gain the skill if you don't have focus
and you're always building a new bridge
every week about the new business that
you're going to do it doesn't matter how
many skills you have and the beliefs you
have about the world zuckerberg couldn't
start 17 facebook so you only start one
you have to stick with it and so that
takes focus this is a really important
point
if you have a trait and this is where
it's helpful to have communities of
other people and ideally mentors etc who
can speak in your life and there's not
even that many mentors who have the
social awareness to say i don't think
you have integrity i don't think you
have focus i don't think you have
discipline i don't think you have work
ethic i don't think you have drive i
don't think you have empathy i don't
think it's patience like these are
virtues these are character traits that
people want to embody as you're like how
do you develop these traits you don't
develop a character trait
you act in accordance to what someone
with that character trait would do and
you do it despite being uncomfortable
doing it so i'll give you an example i
was walking the other day with layla i
was like god i'm so impatient i was
labeling myself as impatient and i've
probably that's been something i've
believed my whole life i was like yeah
i'm impatient i'm an impatient person
i'm go go go go but i also
want to be a more patient person i want
to be wiser i want to be more long-term
thinking and she said you're not
impatient i was like what do you mean i
was like all i want is for all this
stuff to go faster and she's like yeah
but you're not changing direction all
your actions are one of somebody who is
patient
so the fact that you're uncomfortable
being patient does not mean you are
impatient it means you're just patient
and so your internal feelings about what
you're doing have nothing to do with the
trait and so you think about the reverse
of that where someone's like i'm super
disciplined except they don't do
anything that's discipline you're like
no you're not they're like no but i feel
good like yeah but you're not
disciplined you have no evidence to
support that you were disciplined the
idea of building a character trait is
not do i have the character trait or do
i not have the character trait it's to
what extent do i have the trait and so
if you can think about character traits
that way then you can start reverse
engineering the character traits that
you lack and this is really hard because
one of the things that i see with
entrepreneurs all the time is what will
happen is that they will feel bad about
something and then they will want to
change something in their business to
make themselves feel better they take
those emotions and then they try and
feel better by erratic behavior that's
non-directional and then they break
their original strategy the more willing
you are to endure discomfort for an
extended period of time based on a
decision that you made in the past
because you know it's better for your
future means you are more patient
character traits even more than any of
them are a pursuit of perfection that we
will never attain but in understanding
it that way you can see it as a journey
of trying to stack up wins in your favor
you do the thing and you do it so many
times that at some point you look back
and you realize you know what i do do
this most of the time i guess i do own
this trait and then you can label
yourself as a patient man a wise man a
kind man and i think in doing that
you'll ultimately tap into the wall
spring that allows you to grow
beyond your dreams